bonsoir
téléspectateurs de la deuxième chaîne
j'espère que vous avez pu profiter du
conseil de vos radios électricien pour
vérifier cet après midi le réglage de
vaud récepteur rené et le sdf de saint
tropez
faua
à 67 ans il connaît tout le monde et là
une porsche
ok voilà la nordev et tout le monde le
connaît ah ouais la vidéo débute avec
cette voiture de police qui recule et se
met à la hauteur de ce piéton qui est
soudainement aspergé par un jet de gaz
lacrymogène
un geste sans raison apparente le sans
domicile fixe se portent ses mains au
visage
hurle de douleur
ainsi condroz sur le trottoir enfin les
150 euros sera lancée de la journée il
ya dix ans je me faisais quand même des
six appels par mois muriel est venu ici
avec ses trois enfants comme chaque
année malgré un budget est serré on va
se faire plaisir mais sur des choses un
peu moins cher quoi exemple par exemple
des bijoux à 2 euros à la place de les
pays 15 ou 20 euros
on arrive à se faire plaisir tout en
gérant son budget tout augmente sauf les
salaires ça le problème voilà tu devrais
un peu redescendre sur terre de temps en
temps parce que tu as tendance à trop te
prendre pour ce que tu n'es pas si ma
robe est méritée on ce qu'est ce que tu
as rome un méritas sérieux tant que tu
as acheté sur les marchés tu vois tu
parlais et moi on était très belle par
rapport à toi oui si elle était trop
belle irène frachon voilà
les deux parties se mettent d'accord sur
le tarif habituel la famille va louer le
bateau cinq cent mille euros la semaine
c'est un investissement au bord de l'eau
justement il ya ce courageux animateurs
recouvert de poils sous la combinaison
duquel il doit bien faire 50 degrés une
certitude ce soir ce n'était pas un ours
polaire et beaucoup de jeunes femmes qui
ne veulent plus travailler qui est déjà
à 22 ans au 3 ou 3 ou 4 enfants moi je
vois sur ma circo est vraiment combien
de fois ils sont venus me voir pour me
demander ils ont besoin d'un appartement
plus grand parce que et quand je leur
disais mais qu'est ce que vous faites si
vous avez besoin d'une formation et tout
mais c'est comme si je leur brûler les
mains sûres mais n'ont pas tous un loin
de la rive est énormément mais moi je
cherche ma du travail mais certainement
pas
[Musique]
ils ont la pub est
jamais
ils ne savent pas ce qu'on pense qu'en
ils ne savent pas
qui sait
alors les beaux discours de la macro ni
les filiales saab et la perte renie les
feignants sais pas du tout ce que j'ai
dû arrêter que
coûte à l'hôpital importe quoi l'école
mais c'est bon boulot mais c'est mon
boulot déjà et après vous pourrez parler
comme vous aurez réglé des problèmes
et on se calme tout le monde
quoi pour dire les choses simplement ça
c'est un bateau qui si tu achètes celle
en italien va coûter
10 millions 12 millions
l'ayant acheté en turquie on a descendu
la bile après négociation tata pas osé
rentrer chaude 6 millions et comment on
va partager à 3 on a deux millions donc
en gros on peut dire que pour 2 on a un
bateau qui vaut 10 mais pardon pardon et
luisant c'est quand même pas un super
rendement
c'est pourquoi les gens ils n'achètent
pas des actions parce que c'est trop
risqué c'est dur ici du risque
bien sûr olivier s'est allongée j'ai
lâché un gros mot